who's excited to watch a couple
superhero animals for a change with all
the craze surrounding the marvel
universe we're taking you in the booth
for a look behind the voices of dc
league of super pets from booth broships
to impressive new characters all we can
say is that is one strong fido number
one who'd like a superhero pup at your
side we would wake up buddy it is walk
o'clock dwayne johnson's crypto is
everything superman needs he's reliable
and incredibly strong like his character
dwayne is pretty strong and he's also
quite the super actor in hollywood not a
year goes by where we don't see the rock
in theaters even on our televisions he
brings a powerful presence to every kind
of project from drama to comedy is there
anything this guy can't tackle it seems
he got his first desire for lending his
voice to animation since the disney
classic moana became such an
international success who's a good boy
crypto now go fetch some big box office
numbers any ordinary k9 would
number two joining this super animal
cast is the hilarious kevin hart he's
taking on the role of crypto's unlikely
friend ace melon stuff is one of the
greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body like his
co-star hart's a busy man but he
certainly doesn't act like it he brings
the heart to all his projects turning
something
and making it fantastic it looks like he
had quite the time being behind the
booth yet again i should warn you i won
8 bucks not so long ago he brought the
life of pets to commercial success as
the feisty rabbit snowball we don't know
what exactly attracted kevin to this
project but we can guess his buddy pal
dwayne johnson had something to do with
it man
that hurt me as well the past couple of
years or so has proven to us that those
two are almost inseparable on and off
screen they've done a ton of projects
together making super pets just another
buddy film to add to the bff resume
their respective characters seemed the
total opposite at first ace being the
rebellious type and crypto being the
goody two-shoes they always have a habit
of getting their characters back
together though
number three whenever we hear the name
john krasinski a certain tune comes to
mind but now he's long put aside his gym
persona and put on a cape that's right
jon snagged the coveted role of superman
in this one he's got the voice chops too
making milestones in classics like
monsters university and shrek iii we are
not surprised filmmakers thought of jon
for the role he's kind of in the mcu at
the moment so why not coax him into
joining the dc team that's exactly what
he loves doing but he'll do anything
with the rock in it apparently in a post
on instagram the actor revealed he got
the roles saying always wanted to do a
buddy movie with the rock well these are
the roles we were born to play
number four a good team member can go a
long way if any of you have worked in
retail you would have wanted a co-worker
like vanessa bear to keep things
interesting wonder woman has sat like
right where i'm sitting the cast of the
film were lucky enough to grab her for
the role of pb the wonder woman obsessed
pig bear loves playing that character so
much that she even commits with the
costume behind the mic we couldn't
expect anything less from an snl cast
member that's probably why she does so
well in buddy comedy adventures or maybe
it's just her comedic pork chops that
proves she's got the personality for
cartoon characters
number five natasha leone brings on the
voice in her first big time animated
feature so logically casting made her
the role of the speedy turtle merton you
win this round lettuce her voice is so
perfect for this role and with the
top-notch acting she provides it makes
sense now the award-winning actress is
known in front of the camera most
recently taking on the lead role in
netflix's russian dolls and a gas star
on big mouth she can play pretty much
any role
number six when you get one snl alum to
join the party there will always be
another i am lulu kate mckinnon stars as
the feisty and really terrifying guinea
pig villain lulu hamster a hamster she
might have just had a little too much
fun doing this role she just loves the
evil and cute bundle her electric
personality is perfect for lulu and
she's done quite a few animations that
became massive hits bernadand and
finding dory are to name a few but we'll
never forget favorite personalities from
snl what what is it do i have something
on my face do i have a pimple is it
ready should i pop it number seven in a
galaxy far far away diego luna plays an
electric squirrel chip is pretty much a
super anxious squirrel with an
uncontrolled electric power sparking
alongside crypto you're never fine
there's been a ton of buzz surrounding
luna's big new star wars show andor it's
definitely in the works but luckily he
had just enough time to voice this zany
character he certainly got the chops too
as he was a part of disney's book of
life catching the eyes of casting
directors for super pets
number eight i need dogs lots of dogs no
introduction needed who else would be
better to voice batman than keanu reeves
and we mean the ones who have never
played him the past batman were just
fine the way they were he's always
playing the assassin with incredible
moves but now all he's got is his voice
and his voice was featured in one of our
all-time favorites toy story 4. he plays
the same kind of cartoon characters as
his on-screen ones so it's definitely
appropriate to make him the caped
crusader he's bringing on the tough guy
seriousness to batman and we can only
imagine he'll keep those dogs safe or
else
number nine the legendary comedian mark
maron has graced the stage with this
comedy for decades in fact did you know
he holds the record for most appearances
on talk shows that's right he's appeared
over 40 times on the late night with
conan o'brien show and that's just for
one show maybe it's time to grab hold of
another mike for once you've earned it
we guess he did because he's accepted
the role of lex luthor one of superman's
many villains we're actually really
stoked to see a comedian play a villain
role they are usually the most over the
top for sure
number 10 where are you ben schwartz we
have not heard one single detail of his
involvement in the film however we do
know for sure he will be voicing someone
or something how about we put on our
detective hats for a minute who would
the sonic star play in this dc cartoon
like many of the actors mentioned before
he's got quite the range of character
types he's been the funny guy the
annoying guy and the hero so this time
he's gotta play a villain of some sorts
we bet they're keeping his role unknown
until people see the movie as if he's
playing some sort of setup character for
the sequel don't get angry with us we
know there's been a lot of this
character played already but we bet you
anything that he's playing the joker
number 11 with an all-star cast already
why not add another one to the mix
talented actress dasha polanco snagged
the role of green lantern though it is
unknown how involved lantern will be in
the film it's still a really cool
character to voice anyone who follows
dasha will know her as deonera diaz and
netflix's orange is the new black that
and a starring role in the musical film
in the heights she's now able to add
superhero to her bucket list
number 12 david pressman's career has
spanned for decades
starring in pretty much every project
you could think of for this one he's
managed to get the role of corgi an
adorable little pup with a big heart it
may not be a big character but it's
always the background character that
becomes the great underdog of the film
so we'll just have to wait and see there
have been many interpretations of dc
characters but what about an animated
film about the dc super pets and with
kevin and dwayne you can't ever go wrong
there we know we've made some
speculation to who ben schwartz will be
voicing but we want to know who do you
think he'll play
better guess before it's announced